right now let's say someone was buying a  500 000 house just that's it and you're  gonna do a 30-year fixed and you're  gonna put twenty percent down so  standard standard deal  in March of this year you would have had  a three and a half percent mortgage or  an eighteen hundred dollar payment  reasonable you know for a family  right now at seven point five percent  that's twenty eight hundred dollars up a  thousand dollars at  10.25 percent where you and I both think  this is going it's double thirty six  hundred dollars oh it's going there so  the buyers are are being crushed now  let's go the other way let's say the  1800 was all that I could afford as a  buyer when the interest rates at 7.5 the  500 000 house I can afford I can only  afford a 325  000 house so my buying power is down  almost 40 percent